all right with me here as promised in
the hood Peter Lee the head of Microsoft
Research he is going to explain why
Microsoft invest so much in research and
why collaboration with the academic
research community is so vital in these
efforts and in case by the way you've
forgotten you can still submit questions
to Peter for Peter just use the tool
right there on your viewer we'll keep
scanning here Peter welcome thanks for
being here thank you we're gonna put
research in focus officially here I got
to say you quartic you got to kick
things off this morning you came out on
stage and you were talking a little bit
about the overall experience of your job
and as researchers and you used I wrote
it down at the time that it's
exhilarating and terror was the other
word you use and I thought that would
seem like a pretty sort of like being a
parent it's the most exhilarating thing
in my life and I'm always panic-stricken
that's a great analogy I've been using
the analogy of riding a roller coaster
yeah it's something that you just really
want to do you want to be in the middle
of things you want to have the great
experience it's fun yeah it's joyful but
just a little bit scary
also and I think in this past year
Microsoft Research has been put in the
position of getting to ride the roller
coaster let's talk about it from your
from your seat in the coaster you've
been the head of Microsoft research for
a year now what's it been like you know
first thing is every day when I walk
into any of our legs it's this wonderful
feeling you are stepping into the future
you see things around you and you know
there's this inevitability that the
things you're seeing well pretty soon
the whole world is gonna see this stuff
in three or four or five or ten years
you never know exactly one but you know
it's going to happen and so every day it
just feels like I'm stepping into the
future yeah it just is so wonderful
incredible at the same time there's
always pressure we want to get this
stuff out here and and that's where this
exhilaration comes in you know we were
competitive we want to win we want to do
good things for the world and so sorry
and so this combination of this just
thrill of living in a future but also
the drive to put things out is the world
and as you admitted the terror of
needing to deliver right you know when
you finally get to be big enough and
tall enough to get on that roller
coaster yeah and then you get strapped
into the seat that's right and you're
just a happiest person you could
possibly be and then you take off then
you do have sometimes a little shred but
what if I got myself in yeah but it's
the greatest thing in the world
yeah and this might be tough to answer
but what has surprised you the most over
the last year you know I think maybe
there are two things I would speak to
one on the technical side and one on the
business side on the technical side the
kind of continuing rapid advance in deep
neural nets or deep learning as really
shocked me you know it was one thing
when we saw these surprising advances in
deep neural nets to enable speech
recognition to really work in a
practical way and get deployed into all
of our services but now you know it's
not just speech recognition it's
computer vision you know Harry Shum yeah
demonstrated this morning this crazy dog
breed app it's just one of countless
possibilities there similarly we had a
session this morning in the summit on
deep neural nets to get deep
understanding of text of human discourse
and there was just no inkling even two
or three years ago they would get this
far this fast and I've been pretty
surprised more on the business side it
was a surprise to me that such a gave us
such a big vote of confidence and said
we will put a product out that will
eliminate the language barrier through
Skype worldwide that's just a dream that
we've lived with I think for two decades
and now to say suddenly I believe what
you guys are working on we're gonna put
it out there for the world we're gonna
do it this year
I was surprised very pleasant surprised
by the way you get bravery points for
opening the show this morning with what
on many levels certainly in since we're
doing a television version of the summit
this year we're streaming this live in
entertainment and in show business they
always say never work with children or
animals just because they're too
unpredictable and so you actually cross
that barrier this morning you brought
dogs out for folks who missed it
you guys were sort of doing a demo of
Cortana and brought dogs out asked him
what breed asked her what breed these
dogs were she asked for a photo you took
some identified them he was it was
really fascinating stuff you know and
that speaks to the terror because this
is really on the bleeding edge and if
you remember the the person doing the
demonstration at Johnson embassy boy he
then turned Cortana on to my boss Harry
yes to see what kind of dog he is and
and of course Cortana nailed it and said
they're perfect I believe he is not a
terrier and it had the dog but the line
through it
symbol the universal this is not a dog
now you know there's some frivolity of
obviously and dog breeds but you know
what we're on the verge of being able to
do is really give eyes to right tada
right and so imagine what we can do if
we can tell you is that spider poisonous
or not all right
what did Wine Spectator think about that
wine or tell me about the nutritional
content on this plate of food I've just
been given or gee I like that jacket
where can I get one like that it's nice
yeah sure the kinds of things that a
future digital assistant might be able
to do is endowed with the gift of sight
are just limitless and so we're really
really going after that now we've heard
today about the impact that Microsoft
Research is having in the company would
you say there is a renewed emphasis on
making contributions to Microsoft's
product well you know we've always been
very very focused on product impact in
fact every product and Microsoft has
some imprint of Microsoft Research
contributions from
the way I think about it is you know we
have to embrace diversity and so I have
always preached this quadrant model of
research investments if you think about
two dimensions timescales so we have our
short-term research investments things
that only makes sense if we get a quick
payoff Oh in fact I see we have a
prescient and so you see on the x-axis
we have short term to long term
investments sure and then on the y-axis
we have choices of problems and so we
have our reactive problems these are
problems that product teams come to us
saying gee we've really hit a brick wall
can you help us
or sometimes society comes to us with
problems a hospital might say you know
we're really having a problem with
patients being discharged after being
treated for just of heart failure
they're being readmitted in three months
can you help us figure this out and then
as you move up that y-axis we get into
the more open-ended search for truth and
beauty and so what we try to do in
Microsoft research is cover this entire
space we don't want to leave any stone
unturned and in fact we cut this space
into four quadrants that you can see
here in this graphic angle and so in
this lower left corner that's our
product focus that's where we embed our
researchers and with our product teams
and just go after building the best
products and services we can on the
lower right the sustaining quadrant
that's where we work with our product
teams to keep us at the bleeding edge we
want to have everything we do being at
the cutting edge being the best possible
experience best possible value for our
customers but then we have these upper
quadrants the upper right quadrant are
blue sky quadrants this is open ended
blue sky pushes frontiers of knowledge
see what's out there see what's beyond
the headlights and it's incredibly
important that Microsoft Research does
this because ultimately the product
teams are going to be very focused on
meeting the needs or the customers today
someone has to be thinking about where
is the customer going to be two years
five years ten years from now
at least by quadratus death and then
what has gotten a lot of attention
lately is the upper left quadrant and
this is what Harry Shum has been calling
the search of the next big thing
disruptive based on what the world is
today what can we do that shocks the
world then up ends markets that you know
catches our competition unaware those
sorts of things things that change what
people imagine is possible with
technology what if we can eliminate the
language barrier right what kind of
world would that be that's in this right
quadrant and so if there's any renewed
emphasis I think it's on this upper left
quadrant where we're really going for
kind of the things that cause people to
wake up in a different world a world
where new possibilities exist so we also
heard earlier today from harry shum
about some big research bets that
microsoft research has made a catapult
you know can you talk about some of that
stuff quantum just to name a few how are
these projects for lack of a better term
being green-lighted well you know one of
the fundamental foundations of the
philosophy of microsoft research is that
were very bottoms of organization right
and so we really asked our researchers
to integrate with the worldwide research
community and university is really on
every continent be fully aware of the
best ideas that are merging and bring
those ideas into Microsoft and in fact
about 80% of the research we do is done
in collaboration with academic
researchers that's one reason why this
faculty CERN is so important to us it
really helps us engage and in fact give
back to the Research Committee because
they give so much to us and so one way
to think about it is to think of a
venture capital model in Microsoft
Research I provide the Series A funding
for all of our researchers they can seed
efforts that they think are important
based on their interactions with their
colleagues here in Microsoft and
Microsoft Research as well as their
academic colleagues
and then if there's someone who has a
spark of insight that something's really
important so you mentioned project
catapult Doug Berger is working on
reconfigurable computing fabrics with
academic researchers and then is
encountering the end of Moore's Law
approaching and what that means to our
data center operations and he puts two
and two together and says oh my god
there's something big that we have to
address here and with that spark of
insight he's able in Microsoft research
to kind of go after a project like
catapult to see if reconfigure fabrics
can make a big difference in dead center
Wow
and if he's able to do that that happens
really completely without my
intervention or input there's no
approval or green-lighting that I as
head of Microsoft Research have to do of
course there might come a time then when
he's convinced that the company has to
go big here right that we have to deploy
thousands of catapult servers for Bing
and in that point that's where I come in
to help negotiate and broker and make
decisions on what you would call a
Series B level funding okay and bring
that either to our customers or
eternally internal operations and so the
magic I think of Microsoft Research is
that our researchers we say our
researchers have the freedom to pursue
what they think is important but from
management from first perspective it's
magic because we're just getting this
amazing population of series a little
startup idea it's just brewing yeah well
you mentioned that walking into work
every day to you it's just like walking
into the future I mean I was really
walking into this world of innovation
but with that obviously comes a many
layers I'm sure of stress and for you
personally what keeps you up at night I
mean we all have stress nightmares and
you know for me it's something like a
microphone going out and the microphone
won't work wait and then you wake up
what keeps you up at night you know
I have to say not much keeps me up
because one thing about this place is
there's always luxury of no matter you
know just how crazy things seem to be
there seems to be this just
inexhaustible supply of great people and
great ideas it it's something that I
have learned to just count on and in
fact one of the important lessons I've
learned in my time in Microsoft research
is that you can almost never go wrong
betting on the person who has an idea
and passion no matter what you think of
the idea in fact back in 2009 when the
first idea is to use deep learning in a
serious way for speech processing came
out I thought it was the craziest idea I
in fact I I thought it was stupid but
when you look at the passion of the
people and their track records right and
just put your faith in that pretty
consistently great things happen now
having said that of course things do
worry me all the time you know we have
to deliver a great experience for Skype
translator that's something I think
that's going to make a real impact on
people's lives around the world and we
want to do right by all those users and
so I worry and fret over and want to be
a perfectionist on the quality of that
experience sure and in all these things
when we deploy catapults throughout all
of our data centers this will have a
direct impact on how good bigness we
want to deliver on that and when we are
working with our Xbox partners they're
just fantastic people to collaborate
with they have Christmas shipping
deadlines we have to meet those
deadlines with them yeah and so those
things always add certain stressors but
you know I prefer to use exhilaration
again it's like riding a roller coaster
you know what I rather not have those
stresses absolutely not I want that yeah
well speaking of deadlines we're just
about out of time here any final
thoughts on what's happening here and
all the folks watching from around the
well one thing to emphasize is just what
a huge deal it is for us to have this
great relationship with academic
researchers in the u.s. in Europe and
South America and Asia it's something
that just dramatically magnifies what
Microsoft Research and Microsoft were
able to you the kind of enthusiastic
response we get here is just tremendous
for us
in fact in these demos almost all of the
audience members here are great academic
researchers from all the top
universities so we're learning just as
much as they are through all of us and
so I just you know just feel privileged
and really thankful that they're all
here we appreciate it thank you for your
time fascinating informative look at the
the role of research here at Microsoft
we appreciate your time here today as
well here's been nice hanging out with